foreign
and I should like now to observe a
minute of Silence in their memory
thank you
Vladimir Putin making a speech holding a
moment's silence before he continues
um thanking military who have defended
the country
resolution and courage as well as the
consolidation of the entire entirety of
Russian Society has been huge and has
played a defining role in overcoming
these obstacles
and the Mutiny you can see that the Army
society and people were one
this has allowed us to overcome the
extremely dangerous situations that the
country was in
I should like to thank you
contact in the armed forces particularly
with the other bodies
and for your
your faithfulness your loyalty to the
people of Russia